excellent connection
looks like you're ready click here to
start sharing okay you guys ready
yep
all right
i also wanted to say jim and tom jim
here we go we're live now guys get to
talk you ready click your instructions
yeah i'm ready i'm ready yep
all right
welcome everybody to a very special
conversation between
three of my friends
some more
uh older friends than uh than others but
we are
undergoing a debate a conversation
rather not a debate i think most debates
are pointless uh but discussion is very
valuable
and we've had a lot of interest in
getting together members
of different communities communities
from academia represented by me from the
military represented by jim or the
government from by jim and from lay
people who have really been responsible
for getting
this excitement this attention that this
subject needs out to the public and of
course that's speaking of tom delong
who's joining us from to the stars
academy
now jim is joining us from the east
coast jim uh cevavan and my friend kurt
jaymungal who runs a wonderful channel
which you should all subscribe to call
theories of everything i've been a guest
many other guests had on people from
louis elizondo to many others in this
community i'm more of a neophyte novice
and i'm more interested in
doing what galileo said so my hero as
everybody knows who subscribes to my
channel is galileo galilei
here's a finger puppet we're going to
get one of tom and jim at some point
galileo said let us measure what is
measurable and make measurable what is
not and i'm pleased to say i have become
a member of the galileo project at
harvard university which just started uh
just about a couple weeks ago i'm on
their scientific advisory board and i
joined that not because i have so much
free time as the chancellor's professor
of physics at uc san diego and the
co-director of the arthur c clark center
for human imagination but because i
think this is a very very important
subject not the least of which because i
hope to learn some of the physics of the
advanced future if indeed we are being
visited by
a an advanced extraterrestrial
civilization or perhaps as tom calls
them threats in either case
i think it's fascinating so i'd love to
introduce today
my guest and uh first to confirm that uh
my friend kurt is out there and he can
hear us kurt can you please uh can you
please introduce yourself and your
channel
sure my name is kurt jaimungle i'm a
filmmaker with a background in math and
physics i'm particularly interested in
the theoretical ends of physics
something called theories of everything
the channel that i
that i host up that i host podcasts on
is called theories of everything
essentially what are the fundamental
laws of the universe investigating that
as well as the possible connection those
laws have to consciousness and free will
and even god
my interest in ufos is because there
seems to be an intimate tie between ufos
and consciousness there's almost a
direct tie between physics and ufos
because they defy
our known laws and i'm interested in it
i happen to think that innovation will
come from the fringes rather than the
the center or at least be informed by
the fringes
great
and that's that yeah thank you kurt and
i want to remind people who want to
leave uh questions please put it in the
live chat we are live it is thursday
2 38 p.m in the pacific time zone uh
next up is jim a some van who has a very
very impressive biography but i thought
maybe he could introduce himself and
talk about maybe how he came to come to
know tom
oh well thank you very much and thank
you very much for having me on your
program um i've heard about you and i'm
really happy to be
here um
i i met tom gosh what it was about five
years ago tom um
yeah
there was a group of uh
uh
i say intelligence community defense
department people that studied this
topic for a long time
uh very informally and unofficially
and
we had got together i got a phone call
from one of them one day and he said do
you know this fella named tom delong and
i said no he said blink 182 i said no
doesn't ring any bells
he said well he wrote a book called
secret machines chasing shadows and
there's a lot of information in that
book
um
that
that is well
running true to foreign and and it we
don't know whether or not some of the
information on
some of the programs that the u.s
government had was being leaked or not
and we knew that tom
well at least i was told that tom had a
lot of senior
uh government officials that he was in
touch with his his advisors
uh so uh i i we took it upon ourselves
to go talk to mr mr long
and uh and i was the one basically uh
asked why don't you figure it out you
know you're you're the you're the
operations officer you know you did this
for a living so i had a really nice i
flew out to san diego and had a very
very nice chat with tom and it became
apparent right away that tom
not only being a very nice guy but
extremely bright guy but he had put
together
all this data that he had been hearing
and listening to and actually two and
two came out to four i was rather
surprised clearly there was no leak of
that classified information as far as i
was concerned but tom sort of hit the
nail on the head
so i then we had i think breakfast the
next day with some other people doctor
put off
and i won't name the other people that
were there they may not want their names
known but uh luminaries in the field um
and that's when we started uh tom asked
me if we could
maybe
work with him onto the stars and we
agreed to do that and then i think tom
we sketched out a uh
uh what to the stars uh would look like
on a cocktail napkin there and uh and
that was it we shook hands and uh we've
been uh friends ever since uh uh and uh
so it was a lot of fun
great uh that's great to hear and
actually jim i'm sorry tom this will
probably hurt your ego a lot uh but uh
but they they my audience and kurt's
audience are really like they're
impressed that you're on tom but they're
like we really want to hear from jim so
yeah so
all of us are the same way it's the
first time in my life anybody wanted to
hear from me but all right yeah so tom
you uh have many distinctions of course
your guitarist and and you could
probably be on the beach here in san
diego and next time we got to do this in
person down up in encinitas or wherever
but uh but you could spend your whole
days you know cashing royalty checks
from your awesome musical career and yet
you don't do that you don't rest on your
laureate laurel so to speak and you've
taken on this new mission and really you
know i have to confess um you know in
the beginning when i first heard i was
like why is this guy interested he's not
a scientist he's not a military pilot
but you actually made this into an issue
i don't have to say more than almost
anyone in popular culture you've made
this an issue why is this so important
to you
you know i've always been fascinated
with like kind of why we're here and
what this is all about anybody
uh that has any kind of similar wiring
to me um who would understand you know
growing up in a broken family and like
i got kicked out of high school you know
i just read a lot of bad tough kids and
and i and my parents didn't get along
you know and i just looked around a lot
and i said this doesn't make any sense
to me like really like somehow by
accident or some weird design like i'm
just supposed to only care about my
bickering family and my my school that i
didn't really fit into and go and get a
job that i hate so i kind of started
early on on a quest of like not being
like my parents you know and and working
for myself and i was uh i was an artist
i wanted to create things but as an
artist you know
you want people to emotionally get moved
by the art that you're creating the
whole good job of an artist is to digest
the world
and with your point of view you kind of
regurgitate it back to somebody then
they get to digest it and hopefully they
they see other points of view i mean
that's what we do that is our job
description so when i looked around i
was like none of this makes sense you
know what what really moves me would be
like what's the layer deeper than all
this and that's when i started realizing
that there's an entire like kind of
esoteric study out there that deals with
consciousness and ufos and you know
cosmology and all these different things
but really when you when you get into
ufos at first it's fascinating at first
it's like oh my god conspiracy theory
you know this is fun and then you start
kind of going wait some of this [ __ ] is
like real there's no way there's an
astronaut here there's like a president
there's like you know director of the
cia or some admiral and you're kind of
going
wait a second and then you start diving
deeper and then when you dive deeper i
always tell people it's
you're not studying like events really i
mean those are fun and you get into
those the first few years but really if
you study this subject you're like jim
said it's like you know you're getting
into quantum mechanics and you're
getting into consciousness and you're
looking at archaeology differently and
petroglyphs and stuff and you're
starting to really soak in all the
branches of the tree um and it seemed to
me
that all those things combined it really
created a glue in my mind at least that
tied together so many disparate ends of
what mankind is all about and what's
been going on it almost fit like a
perfect puzzle piece not that i know
everything i don't know if anyone does
but for me and and it just became very
um evident that this was like oh my this
is a puzzle piece that fits it fits
in all these things that i grew up you
know um having interactions with from
like religion to
government national security stuff to
advance technology stuff to the history
of mankind and so on and i'm still on
that quest but um
on another note it's the only thing that
ever took me out of the maddening kind
of obsession of trying to write a better
song like when you're in a band it's
or you're painting a painting any kind
of art it's only going to be as good as
how much time you can put into it and um
so what you end up doing is putting all
your time into it especially if you work
for yourself it's like your wife's like
join the family and you're at playing
guitar at one in the morning go no i
gotta figure out this melody well this
is like the one thing that got me out of
that because i i need to learn all the
time
i don't really like like predictable
movies i don't like normal fiction books
and stuff but this was like a fiction
story
but that has a bunch of things you can
learn it's like it's just as fascinating
but you can really enrich your mind and
soul by diving into some of these
branches of the tree you know so
here i am 20 years later i put some good
pieces together um
but
as genitalia the first day i met jim i
was like thank god you know he's like
who are you and what are you doing and
i'm like i'm looking for somebody to
work with me i i think we can do
something great for the world i just
don't really know how to do it by myself
i need i need some help and and
thankfully
jim and a bunch of the people that he
knew and was working with felt the same
way it's
it was just a good time to come together
do you ever get um you know kind of the
i'm sure you've had your share of of
negative influences maybe people that
don't like you in some way for your
music or your or this research do you
find any commonalities though in kinds
of the support or maybe the negative
attention that you get uh because you
know on the face of it yes there are
aspects of it but i would think naively
scientists pilots etc we'd be the most
interested but you made the interesting
point that it's part of culture and
people don't appreciate that science is
a form of culture too uh equal in every
respect in my opinion uh to arts and you
know and letters and so forth so do you
find commonality there tom just from the
two different careers that you've had
um i do i mean
you know it's funny like one of the one
of the when i was working with um
and i was building relationships with
people before i knew jim that work you
know high-ranking former government
officials or military people and stuff i
remember i wanted to thank them um for
their time listening to me you know and
so
one way to thank them that i came up
with was in
the government kind of military
industrial complex world they all create
these challenge coins have you ever seen
the challenge coins where it's like that
one here yeah i've got one you got one
there well for the people watching it's
like you know these little coins that
have like your platoon name on there
maybe the things you believe in maybe
it's the operation you're a part of yeah
here's one uh from my buddy in
afghanistan yeah they all make um um
there you go
so these little coins you bring them out
of bars and you owe each other drinks
depending on who's got a better coin or
whatever so i decided to make a
challenge point and i put on the
vitruvian man which was uh da vinci's
you know
two arms two you know or four armed four
legs kind of thing but what that stood
for was art and science and what i
really liked about that and this all
comes full circle to your question was
um art and science to me was something
measurable with something that's
infinite you know it's consciousness and
zeros and ones to some degree but when
they come together um i think for the
longest time we've always separated
consciousness and things that we don't
understand
and we put it in religion we just go
that's god's world so we can't know that
we can't measure that um yeah there you
go and um and so consciousness in
metaphysics and things we don't
understand was supernatural paranormal
um and it was in the realm of the old
testament or something you know um or
other religions um but the vitruvian man
this idea of bringing consciousness and
science or art and science together
because art is really just a stream of
consciousness you're making things up so
the question is is where are you getting
that you know you're you're some type of
antenna and you're pulling it from
consciousness in my view um so i use
this on the challenge point to say look
as an artist and as something that's
scientifically based here if we can
merge these together the future of
science i think is going to be once we
understand consciousness we take the the
realm of what used to be all religion or
something and we merge it with science
and now we got like this theory of
everything um so i wanted to say that my
my um
project was that it was an artist
working with things that are tangible
tangible and measurable and so i made
these challenge coins i put the
vitruvian man on there um and i gave
them to everybody and and um for me i
got the same rush
as being an artist but with this because
i really felt that i was
i was
putting something together with a point
of view that people
really haven't been able to spend time
with or study or look at or notice
um
and it became kind of like the guiding
north star the light you know was the
merging of these two things um and it's
just been a hell of a lot of fun along
the way i believe it kurt uh would you
like to ask uh you had some comments and
questions for jim do you want to take it
from here
yeah
first i want you
tom and jim and the audience to know
that i'm not a skeptic nor a debunker
i'm more of a
i'm curious and i'm clueless
when i research this topic i'm just
baffled and bewildered constantly i
don't know what to think
so
when i spoke to travis walton recently
some people thought that i was a skeptic
that's actually not true i i'm asking
detailed questions because i want to
know what was the air like on this alien
ship i want to know what did the glass
rod feel like was it heavy was gravity
the same and so on so if i ask you
detailed questions please it's out of a
place of love i'm curious to know about
skinwalker
but you're asking jim right
i can ask
whoever wants to answer
what's going on at skinwalker and what's
its connections to
what's its connection to ufos
uh
well i am by no means an ex expert on
skinwalker ranch uh tom and i know
uh all the people that are involved
george uh calm uh kelleher and george
knapp keller her
uh i've never met mr bigelow i was
supposed to at one point but it never
never happened but um
uh there is
i think that that's a fascinating case
uh the
uh i think but i i don't know whether i
can actually discuss that in any kind of
meaningful way because i wasn't there
and i wasn't part of it i read the book
like everybody else i john alexander's a
dear friend of mine and you know he was
there and we talk about it quite a bit
um i think uh what had happened there uh
was true and accurate and real
uh but uh i also believe that when you
go looking
for the phenomenon
uh it basically doesn't show itself uh
it doesn't like to do that and after 40
years of studying that
you know it's it's that low
observability thing going on you know
why we can never get a good picture of
uap for some strange reason it doesn't
want to go there so you mentioned
earlier you're dazed and confused well
yeah i'm about as dazed as confused as
you are by the whole thing i have my own
opinions based on what i know and based
on what i've read but um
skinwalker is fascinating i i you know
from everybody i know that been there
and done that including
some people that were not mentioned in
the book which i don't want to get into
but uh
it's uh
it's a pretty serious place and a lot of
serious things happen there um
but i'll let tom go
go and talk more about that
sure you know i what i find fascinating
about skinwalker is that um you
basically have the convergence of
multiple
you know things happening you know so
when you look at ufos you can find
stories where
somebody might come out and their cattle
are missing or
there's um you know a cattle mutilation
where blood is gone or parts of the jar
are dissected maybe an eyeball's gone
maybe the reproductive reproductory
organs are gone or whatever um and a lot
of like really
weird things about it like maybe the
cuts are in between cells maybe there's
no vascular collapse maybe it happened
within 10 minutes when the farmer turned
around or something then you have um
people that might have seen lights in
the sky the day the night before when it
happened or you know then there's people
that have paranormal feelings they might
have seen
like you know some type of entity that's
invisible or something they weren't
quite sure then you have poltergeist
events and other houses whatever but
what's weird about skinwalkers they were
all happening there you know so you have
all these things happening in one
location but as jim said it's like
super elusive um it's almost like it'll
watch you be there for a week and then
the night you're driving away to go home
it's like you look at your rear view
mirror and there's something crazy you
know and it almost toys with you that
was something that they all seemed to
say like it seemed like it knew
that you wanted to see something you
want to do something whatever what i
find fascinating is that you have this
one location where so many things are
happening and it's documented by a bunch
of government people a bunch of phd
scientists a bunch of people that have
lived there and um and not only
documented over like a few months we're
talking like decades you know
and it's kind of a hot spot where you
can kind of dig into
trying to find why are they all
happening at this one location and and
what interests me is that i think it
gives us
a potential pathway to discuss some
alternate um
candidates for where they're from or
what they're doing or how it all works
like i think most people like to think
of ufos is they're coming from another
planet you know we found an exoplanet
and it's coming there and how do they
travel well they could do it in 30 years
if they go fast well the data doesn't
seem to suggest that really it it it's
more what's happening at skinwalker
where it seems like
it's more about frequencies and
dimensional or
they materialize it's almost like their
displacement craft that displaces our
time like a submarine would in the ocean
um and that was a lot of what dr
halpudoff worked on on atip was
understanding the attributes of the
propulsion and the science that they're
using and i think once you think about
ufos using that kind of a technology
then it's kind of like well if they do
that if they use that that means there's
things that are adjacent to us
that we don't see we don't understand
but are like right here and every once
in a while they can kind of cross over
is it because we're aware of it and can
see it and that opens it or is it
because it's a geomagnetic
area where where those types of things
have an easier time coming through
um or is it everywhere and we just think
it's in one location i don't know i mean
there's a story that even happened there
where they like
you know they were there and they and
you're talking about government
grade phds where they watch
you know something in the atmosphere
open up and something come through not
sure what it is
and and it was a huge event so they run
down to grab the cameras and see what
was on the cameras they open up these
lock boxes and then like all the
electronics are missing and the cameras
and they're like wait what like these
were locked up and who took it's like a
game and so it gets really interesting
where
is it a game i don't know but it might
be a consciousness thing and so
i get passionate about a place like that
because it gives you the ability to do
to really jump into some wild stuff i
mean one of the scientists there
was walking through a field and they
basically saw um you know they saw they
walked past um
like a cow or something and then they
turned around it was gone
and then like 10 minutes later they're
like where is it they turn back around
and there it is on the ground just out
of nowhere with like two broken legs so
they run in the ground i might only
polite
it was no it was alive you know and then
they run back into
the the house to go grab a gun or
something to take care of it and when
they come out now it has four broken
legs you know or something it's like
creepy and and and like causing
alarm because it number one it makes no
sense number two it's like it's
happening so quick that they can't even
um and i got family showing up from the
beach you know you see people behind me
but um you mentioned the beach they all
went to the beach earlier but um
what it seems to be is that it's it's
you know an issue with
time
um and an issue with
moving it like from here to here where
we can't see it and back and then people
will see crap and then i don't know it's
it's just wild and it and it's so
fascinating and i always tell people in
hollywood because you know to the stars
is getting into making like
movies and tv series and documentaries
and stuff and i just you don't need to
sensationalize this stuff you don't need
to come up with
um
like like science fiction type um
you know ideas to make it intriguing i
mean it's it is it's it's wild the way
it is you don't have to do much to it
have you come up with any theories as to
why cattle mutilations occur
me personally
or heard any that you found to be
incredible
well i wouldn't have any science to back
anything up so i could tell you i'm a
dreamer you know so i can come up with a
bunch of ideas i have sun
um you know i've heard scientists
discuss
you know tracking our food supply you
know trying to see if there's
things that are in our food supply that
are affecting kind of how we evolve okay
that that was an interesting and there's
a lot more to it but it's not my place
to get into that um i've heard people
discuss that you know it's genetics or
something it's it's understanding
um a bit more about you know the life
here on earth or whatever then you get
into way more far out stuff is maybe it
has something to do with genetics with
man because maybe bovine type samples
deal with
you know the blood or the i don't know
like the glands or something have to do
with you know people want to go way out
and be science fiction about it but i i
just don't know and i think
i just think that what we are hearing is
that
people are seeing lights and craft in
the sky in areas where they find these
things we know they're happening and
have been happening for decades and
decades like not just like a few like
thousands you know um but no one really
knows the reason why
maybe someone somewhere in some basement
knows but i i don't want to pretend that
i know because i don't but i do know
people been studying this for like 30
years and and um
and they all tend to say the same thing
it's like it's happening in a way
that doesn't look like we can pull off
what we're finding it just looks way i
mean they found cattle with organs like
their heart missing but no incisions
anywhere like somehow they reached in
and just grabbed it and pulled it out
you know so it's like what does that
mean what is it i don't know but it's
it's it's wild for sure
there doesn't seem to be any
muted brian oh sorry yeah so how do you
take the reaction in terms of you know
people coming um and saying you are
basically a repository for people to
come forward to come out etc uh that you
know it's sort of a unique role for you
tom right uh it's it's now you're almost
like a priest and confessional and and
people coming exactly i mean
how is that how do you deal with that
pressure how do you deal with the with
the notion of you know kind of this this
you become the face and symbolizing a
lot of this and and there's a wonderful
clip that one of your fans put out on
twitter i saw yesterday or a couple days
you know it's like what you said in 2017
on you know joe rogan show and then like
slowly as they say you know first
creative ideas are dismissed as lunacy
then they're mocked then they're
ridiculed then they're accepted as
trivial and known all along so now that
these you know pentagon report which we
have to get into and maybe i'd love to
hear get jim's take first on that um jim
when this came out did you feel like uh
it answered more questions for me if i
felt like it answered more questions i
mean honestly i am a skeptic i have to
say as a scientist there's no one tom
and jim kurt already knows this that
would be more kind of thrilled delighted
to skip the line as my friend james
altitude says and go from the physics of
2021 to the physics required maybe 2121
or beyond i would love to do that first
of all i'd get you know multiple nobel
prizes second of all i would satisfy the
personal curiosity that sounds like tom
and jim and kurt we all have to
understand the nature of reality because
let's face it guys we're only here for a
short amount of time we're given maybe
the biblical age of 120 that's about it
um but uh but if we could skip that line
avoid death avoid you know interstellar
uh you know kind of have the secrets to
this to these to these advanced uh
technologies and to advance knowledge
that to me is the pinnacle of what homo
sapiens could achieve jim when you look
at this when you hear
uh these complaints and and so forth
people being skeptic do you feel like
skeptics have a point i mean are we just
like kind of curmudgeons and we're just
not hearing the truth uh that you guys
are telling or you know
you have feet in both worlds you're in
the military and the you know government
uh but you're also in the in the
community that that tom's in what do you
feel
is the right approach here believe
everything believe nothing how do you
split those uh those atoms yeah i mean i
yeah that's an excellent question and i
think i think you just said it uh you
know believe everything believe nothing
uh i'm not a skeptic uh but it ain't
stretching the imagination um and when
the
i was not surprised at least when the uh
uh when the uap task force report came
out i i understood what it was going to
be
uh it's just an adam bration it was an
outline
of what they're planning on doing
there's no way they can put together
any kind of substantive report any kind
of intelligence assessment based on this
in the short amount of time that they
had and they only took you know 144
incidents my god i mean that's and just
from the navy i
i mean there are hundreds of thousands
of incidents that have happened that
credible witnesses have seen so i i
wasn't surprised
i thought the the the writing in there
was uh obviously done by the dni it was
very
very well crafted very tight writing i
think they took some pot shots at the
air force which i'm glad they did
because i don't know where the hell the
air force has been in all this
actually i sort of do but
um
but the most important piece i felt uh
was the deputy secretary of defense memo
they came out at the same time that was
issued on july 25th
that memo came out and said
knock it off
cat's out of the bag
we are going to go after this we're
going to we're going to develop
requirements and requirements that
basically means that it's an
intelligence term for uh for questions
we're going to develop these questions
everybody's going to have to answer them
and and and and we're going to put money
towards this we're going to put people
towards this that's huge that's
absolutely huge and um and so i thought
i was very very happy when when i saw
that
now
when they talked about in the report you
know they have these these areas these
categories you know about what they
think it could be you know
air clutter and and what have you and
then going down it could be this it
could be that it could be the russians
or chinese
uh look i i've i've studied russian and
chinese high technology
for my whole career
this these uaps
or whatever the hell they are i mean we
call them uaps we really don't know what
they are
um they're not russian and they're not
chinese and they're definitely not ours
they're just not
that leaves nothing
left except they're something else and
what that's something else is i don't
know i i i was on tv a couple weeks ago
when i called it
i was prodded by the producer i said say
something say something
and i i called it i called it a a
non-human technology and i i guess
that's the best way i can go
but i don't think science
right now
has the ability to look at this
in a way that they want to look at it
and it's not their fault and i i it's
because you know there's no reliability
here there's no predictability here
uh this this phenomenon
plays with us
it teases us it cajoles us it gets close
but you can't get too close to it uh and
sometimes it appears to people up close
and personal other times it doesn't but
if you notice with the navy i mean you
know what is it actually saying i mean
you know are they trying to communicate
with us or are they basically just
trying to affect us socioculturally
when you talked earlier about
cattle mutilations hell yeah cattle
mutilations are real don't really know
what's happening with them
but when you look at what the real
effect of that is
the real effect of that is it's all of
us sitting here and looking at that
and all of a sudden our cultural norms
and social norm we get if things change
and things change but i know jacqueline
talks about this quite a bit and i'm a
huge fan of his um
are they here to basically change us are
they more of a control mechanism and it
you know
you know and and and the answer that we
don't know we have tons of questions
zero answers i think science has a huge
huge way ahead of them i mean it's going
to be very very difficult
um but i don't think we have any uh you
know options except to investigate this
but it's clearly
not human encouragement not even as we
know it yes
kurt you've had jock on what are your
takes and also kevin knuth who's a
physics professor in new york state uh
talk about your peregrinations your
explorations of this phenomenon kurt
what have you
uh kind of surmised as a physicist as a
scientist what what kinds of uh thoughts
do you have about
approaching this from the colleague of
as you know our colleagues are very
skeptical of some of these claims cattle
mutilation what does that have to do
with physics what does that have to do
with aliens and other planets and where
would they come from how would they get
here how could these are anyway
kurt
my brother tell me what do you make of
your
explorations of this as a topic
how have you been influenced changed
perhaps not mutilated but how has your
mind got mutilated in a certain sense
where do you stand now
well i'm probably much like most people
here used to be a staunched skeptic an
ardent one an arrogant one not saying
that you're one you're not arrogant at
all brian but most are let's say
that's not true
and
and now i don't know what to think i
don't know if you've played this game
called metal gear solid but at some
points you get when you get spotted
there's an exclamation point that goes
over the guard's head i feel like that
all the time just
constantly what the heck is happening
what the heck is this what does this
mean how does this fit with this
so i don't know i don't even know if
there's one alien species if it's a
subspecies if there are aliens to begin
with if it's multiple races if it's
factions
i don't know
can i add something into the
conversation let me let me give you the
government perspective on this um as an
intelligence officer for a long long
time i will tell you
that back in 1945 actually you know this
phenomenon has been seen since the
beginning of time all major religions
have talked about it
uh we started seeing more of it in the
40s actually during world war ii and
then later on afterwards um when general
twining came out
1947 and basically said look these are
real these are serious we're gonna have
to look at it and then we had project
sign project grudge and then you know
the um and you know blue book and then
we had all these other things the uh
condom report and what have you
where they basically came out and said
screw it we're not gonna do this anymore
absolute nonsense there's no way that
the air force or the intelligence
community is going to give up on
something like this that is that is a
very very real
phenomenon that we don't i don't think
it's a threat at all to be honest with
you i just i think it's totally
indifferent to who the hell we are but
but nevertheless it has to be looked at
the military in the intelligence
community does not
ignore that they will not ignore that
and you know and and and this it's
always going to be bubbling up in the
background it may be in some deep black
program some hidden someplace but i
would be shocked and surprised if that
isn't what's going on that we haven't
been seriously studying this
for the last 70 or 80 years nothing just
there's no way there's no way when you
look at the stargate program
that was a direct reaction to
soviet uh experiments in in psychic
phenomena
they were doing that we had to figure
out why they were doing that and what
they found out and i can tell you other
stories
i mean crazy technologies you think
didn't know exists but actually do exist
and and you you find out that other
other countries are working on them or
trying them and what have look there's a
huge
national security element in all this
too so i mean you know nobody wants to
share this data publicly because as they
say you know you tell your friends you
tell your enemy so a lot of that stuff
is hidden and i don't blame the
government for hiding a lot of this
stuff either if there is a true and
honest national security uh uh problem
associated with this but you know i i i
just find it extremely difficult uh
with skeptics who who who tell me like
when they see this stuff and they go
well i don't know what it is look at
that's agreeable i mean i i don't know
what it is either but it is there
and no one has an answer to it and and
please don't tell me it belongs to you
know china or russia or some other
that's just nonsense i think that was an
out that the uap task force had to use
um um i mean once you've read the
literature once you've been read and
it's read in on some of these programs
it's just i'm sorry it just i i'm not a
skeptic that did exist i just don't know
what the hell it is you know when i when
i look at that data and you know i'm
going to ask each of you to steal man
your quote opponent's perspective in
other words what's the best argument
you've heard counter to your own
position jim and tom especially but
before i do that i want to just make
take a reset and tell everybody who
we're talking to tom delong of course to
the stars academy and also jim simvan of
to the stars academy former uh cia
employee and kerche mungle host of the
theories of everything channel which has
done yeoman's work kurt you're you're
really a role model in many ways to many
youtubers we've got a lot of people
listening jeremy reese in the in the
chat room and many other people but tom
i want to ask you when i hear talk to my
fellow scientists about this and i talk
to somebody who's a member of i don't
know if you're familiar with this
organization called the jason's jason's
secret i'm sure jim knows about them too
so they actually meet here in
in san diego uh once a year at least
they did before covet and they tell me i
said wouldn't you think like the best
and brightest would be at least
interested and involved in this and they
said nope i'm not we're not they haven't
asked us the government hasn't asked us
to investigate it we're not just going
to go off and investigate stuff on our
own um why would this organization
assuming he's telling me the truth and
she there's actually multiple people
members of the jason's have told me the
same thing no we're not investigating
these phenomena uh is that insulting to
you how do you take that is that proper
skepticism that is a
counterproduction my in my experience um
in my experience even the people that
are very much involved on this stuff
would tell you that exact same answer
you know jim can explain
security clearances and national
security stuff i i can't i i'm not
i don't know that kind of stuff i just
know through osmosis kind of how it's
treated but um
i when i first met a bunch of people
that were involved on this subject
before i even knew jim i remember
specifically
you know i was in
one place and you know there's a big big
wig i was talking to and he goes you
know
um you know we don't
ever look at that subject we don't care
about that subject there's absolutely no
evidence whatsoever that any of that is
even real
yadda yadda and i was like okay um
thanks and then i left that person's
company
uh or that that person's table and went
right outside the door and there's these
other two guys that work directly under
them that said we want to talk about
this and they talked about it for an
hour you know and it was like nothing
classified they can't go there but it
was just like some people are more open
to it and some people aren't but the
people that are
dealing
directly with something that's
classified they're never going to even
talk about it you know um as far as the
best and the brightest i guess that's
subjective because
you know who knows if the jason's really
are or not i've always heard that they
kind of were you know but i think that
you know you have incredible people at
the national academy of sciences you
have incredible people at the national
laboratories you have incredible people
at the the lockheed martins in the
boeings and uh they're everywhere and i
think that
um it's not exclusive that we need this
one group of scientists or whatever who
knows if something's been studied for
decades and decades they're going to
choose people that are the best and the
brightest that can keep their mouths
shut because it probably has these big
national security elements that come
with it
and they're going to find people that
bring value in ways that they need it's
not just like a blanket like you're a
great scientist we're going to bring you
in i mean i as far as i know and what
i've learned
you know black programs don't really
work that way but i'll tell you directly
directly direct experience
that
um in the very beginning everyone said
that to me and and because they had they
don't need to open up a conversation
with me they don't need to talk about it
they're not going to get anything out of
it if anything they're just going to get
in trouble or make them feel like they
need to go back and report a
conversation where something slipped or
something so i just don't think that's
the right
route but
but what i will say is i talked to the
former head of the task force uh before
it's in its current form however that
works and i asked him i said what's the
biggest change
uh
now that we we were able to bring the
ufo subject out into the mainstream and
he told me he said for the first time
ever we can talk about this in the halls
of the pentagon up until this point you
know it was always in a skiff
underground somewhere yeah you know and
we heard similar things from
alexanditritch who's a renowned fighter
pilot who was involved along with uh
with commander fraver and the so-called
tic tac incident and one very valuable
thing that this is elucidated is the um
breaking down those barriers the the the
insecurity the you know humiliation the
the kind of taboo or military pilots who
are you know heroes far beyond what i'm
capable of doing and uh and they
volunteer to put their lives on the line
if these are military threats or even
weather balloons or whatever uh that we
owe it to our war fighters to to make
sure that they're safe and secure so
taking taking away the taboo has been
incredibly important for me kurt do you
have some questions uh from your
audience or from you that you want to
pose because these uh gentlemen have a
hard cut out in about 40 minutes 30 40
minutes
yeah there's this person named red panda
koala tom have you seen the documentary
on yourself
okay a wonderful concise 60 minute
summation of your work in
this ufo topic and here or she
asks what was
what was it that tom was told that kept
him up for three days
oh well i don't talk about that but
there was i remember
um
i remember having discussions
the company that i keep with people like
jim they just
you know in how and
the this the way their minds what's
really cool about jim by the way is that
i've learned how to parse information a
lot better i'm not going to ever be you
know
him you know this guy is master spy you
know but but i don't i don't i learn a
lot like i like
learning how to
be a little bit more i'm skeptical of
information and being able to put these
things together and think differently
but they're all such
um
really big thinkers and they don't just
grab onto a piece of data because it
exists and says oh this matters and this
means everything it's very much like
forming patterns and analyzing over time
so i remember like hanging out with all
these guys in the beginning and and i
and one of the bigger things um
was just about me understanding the
stakes of this because you come into
this as a and this kind of answers your
question about like what keeps me up at
night or what kept me up when i was
discussing things was not understanding
the stakes not really coming to grips
with this being real like it's one thing
when you when you see a video or you
read it in a book you know and you're
like whoa this is all you know but you
don't know if the video is real that's
why it was so important with the ones we
brought out had chain a title all the
way back to the dod so we knew those
were real it wasn't just like it was on
youtube and leaked um so it's it's the
idea of bringing forth things that you
know
where they come from and and you really
take it from that point forward and
start um getting really good data and
evidence on people's encounters and the
stakes that come with that and that when
when i've talked about this
as a threat you know this is that's just
my words right i mean i would never know
the way the government
treats that that's not my my zone
obviously
but for me in my own personal research
if something's been here for a long
period of time and it really is showing
up in people's bedrooms or in front of
an f-18 or on a petroglyph wall or in an
ancient text down in the archives of the
vatican or whatever it might be it's
obviously doing something and it's
obviously having an influence and it
might only be an influence on where we
end up as mankind or it might be an
influence to keep us suppressed in a
weird way to where they can take
advantage of something who knows um but
it's here for a reason and it's not
really being you know forward about its
intent but we do know that we've been
dealing with it for a long period of
time and so when you start coming to
like the way they think and the stakes
involved in the reality of it um and you
and i start hearing about these
encounters from the people that were
there
um
i remember in regards to the question
you asked
i was out in colorado springs and i had
a meeting with a couple generals
and we were just shooting the [ __ ] about
all this stuff um and something was
discussed that
you know it wasn't some big classified
thing it was more like
things that people are are having happen
to them or witnessing
and it's an issue and i remember waking
up in the middle of night just go i i
was like you start to look around you
not really trust your environment you
know it's like whoa like really like
this is real like my mom is a is really
religious like she's like a born again
christian and in hardcore fanatic you
know religious woman and
and and i grew up in a household my dad
wasn't so that's part of like the big
budding of the heads and uh it was a
broken home but i remember thinking at
that time frame when i was um
talking about some of these things that
i just want to discuss uh where i was
where i couldn't sleep very well was i
was like if my mom really believed that
jesus
is real and would show up in her room
and float towards her with a crown of
thorns i mean she would break she would
have a heart attack
that would scare her even though she
bases her whole life on it like who she
hangs out with where she goes on
weekends and weeknights who she might
date or marry again um every call she
calls me she's praying but if she so she
believes this viscerally but if she saw
something like that
it's a different deal once it's like
really real it's not just reading in a
book and believing in it and that's kind
of what i came to with the whole ufo
thing it wasn't just like believing it
it was like oh my god this is real this
is like real not just that we're talking
about it and we saw it on the news or we
saw it on youtube it's like when you're
alone in your bedroom in the middle of
the night you got to look around and go
[Music]
who knows what can happen and
that's kind of where i've landed over
the past few years it's just like going
anything is possible
does your mom think that what you're
doing is an act of evil or you're
studying evil that you shouldn't be
doing what you're doing
she loves me too much and is too
supportive to have that thought so in
her head it's like this it's probably a
crisis of conscience you know where it's
like these don't all map up you know but
this is what i i tell people um and and
i really believe this i'm not speaking
for gem or the company this is my own
personal thing
i i have a feeling
that when we when we really learn about
consciousness and we really learn
kind of what these these things are this
phenomena is i think we're going to like
i said earlier we're going to merge this
metaphysical consciousness type of
science with normal science and once it
becomes all one we're going to look at
we might look at religions differently
but i think everyone's going to be able
to keep the things they love which is
really not all the dogma and the stories
that we argue about but when it comes
down to
you know the father the son the holy
spirit or godhead um
your soul and the physical body it's all
the same three things that trinity thing
is like kind of everywhere it's all
about
you as a person with your connection to
consciousness you know the father the
son the holy spirit kind of thing so i
think what will happen is everyone's so
scared that religions will crumble and
i'm kind of like no it's going to be the
great equalizer that the only three
things that matter in all of these
things is
us as a physical person with our
connection to something bigger and um
and i and so i don't think people are
going to be alienated i don't think they
might you know be bummed that the story
of the locusts coming out didn't apply
you know or something but i think that
the things that matter stay
which is you know i used to go to my mom
and say like you know i'll go why are
you a christian like why like what is it
show i i know it i've seen things i've
felt things i just know in my heart but
then you know and she goes and we've
healed the blind we prayed and they can
heal the blind that's happened i'm all
but that's happened in islam too
it has so why is it happening in other
religions and here and my whole point
was it's not about the stories it's it's
it's physics and um and people like
yourself are going to help us all
understand that here in the future you
know yeah
so uh so jim and tom a question from
sarah skulls who's a friend of mine i
wrote a book they are already here
uh about in part about tom uh she's a
she's a wonderful soul uh she asks about
you know where do things go from now uh
and here maybe uh now that elizondo luis
elizondo and chris mellen aren't part of
ttsa
um how does that affect your mission
guys is that is that you know should
that how should that be interpreted you
know if you were not being you know uh
charitable you might say oh that's a you
know that's a sign they have internal
strife and you know what what but is
there some other explanation or you know
where do you see things going now that
these two very prominent you know
supporters of the narrative uh that you
guys are also you know supporting have
departed from ttsa at least i understand
from jim that you guys are on good terms
but where do you go from here yeah
well i mean a lot there's so much going
on number one the pandemic we're
startups so we're not giant you know we
have we have more people from the
government that want to be a part of
what we're doing than we have space for
so that's not the issue with those
people in particular when the pandemic
hit it really
caused us as a young company to choose
one lane rather than trying to do
multiple lanes and during the pandemic
the defense authorization act they
didn't they couldn't get it passed they
couldn't fund any more uh research
projects with new companies new programs
and we were a new company with a new
program um so we were kind of stuck in
this like quicksand of waiting and
waiting to try to get some things off
the ground but where we had a you know a
ton of traction was in the entertainment
part where we already had product
selling we had movies coming we had tv
series coming and so it just created um
an opportunity to focus the company and
get everything really streamlined to
grow quickly without trying to dilute
ourselves in places where we can't
compete with a lockheed martin or
whatever but we really wanted to get
these things off the ground some of
these early programs some of which hal
is still chasing some of which like we
still have an open contract with the
government on some of the material that
we got but chris mellon without i don't
want to speak for him but i do know
chris is involved in a lot of things
back in dc specifically with trying to
get this thing pressed through congress
and with oversight and the task force
and he's so deep in it that um i think
it frees up a lot of time and gets him
kind of
away from the entertainment part which
you don't really it doesn't mix well
with the government stuff and jim it'd
be better for you to talk about some of
this stuff but that was what we kind of
found was some of those issues i guess
yeah
that's pretty much it and and um um you
know i think i think chris needed to go
uh his own way as with lou they wanted
to pursue other things that that weren't
quote unquote entertainment focus
i get that completely and they are they
are doing i think it's just an
outstanding job uh both of them you know
i'm just
huge fans we're all huge fans of them
they they were really courageous to do
what they did uh they had uh their
reputations and you know lou i had met
with before while he was the head of
atip and
i sort of done some unofficial
consulting with him uh early on and um i
just my hat's off to him it's just a
great great man as with chris so they're
they're doing i think they're doing
god's work you know so i we're we're
huge fans any way we can help them we
certainly will
in terms of the partnership between ttsa
and the government there was i didn't
actually see this but according to my
friend mick west he says j.j abrams ufo
documentary episode 3 suggests ttsa
might be part of a government
disinformation program that's what i
signed up for i was like how do i lie to
my friends and my family
can i just comment on that first of all
you know that's that's rather insulting
it's insulting you know not only to me
and you know and all the people that
work for the government what have you
you can't have a disinformation program
in the government it it's it's illegal
you can't do that um i wouldn't do that
personally i mean that's just that's
terrible and and you know you cannot
influence the population of the united
states that you government governments
can't do that it's called an operation
and you can't have that uh it's it's not
we we don't do that and um uh as a
matter of fact you know it's one of the
reasons i don't like going on shows
because when people come up with these
questions you know you sort of sit there
and you look at them and say well if you
really knew how the government worked
um you know when i was in cia i mean you
know when i was in the senior service at
one point i was running rather large
programs
i had lawyers all around me i mean you
couldn't make a decision without making
sure that you were right on the money
and we ci in particular it's a great
organization i mean they made a lot of
mistakes in the past but by and large
it's a very very straight-laced
organization you do not do anything uh
that would in any way harm a u.s citizen
or uh or uh or the population in general
so that's uh that's bogus yeah i know
okay and i appreciate that so much and
believe me you know and no one has more
respect that didn't serve at least than
me i mean my mystery and i like that
yeah yeah but i think i do want to say
you know i mean one thing just to
criticize um the government that i do
love and support and that's the best
country on earth i'll say that uh uh
except maybe canada kurt's gonna speak
up about the 51st state to the north up
there but anyway in all seriousness you
know i look at kova 19 and i look at you
know the trillions of dollars that go
from our 16 of our entire budget goes to
the military cia fbi all these nsa we
didn't i remember going to dinner in
2020 in january 2020 my friend told me
you just got an invitation to go to
china are you going to go brian i said i
don't know and he said you shouldn't go
because china's building this hospital
slash prison they're going to start
locking people in because this thing
called covet i said okay well i'll keep
my eye on i'm not gonna go to i'm not
not rushed to go to tibet anyway i'd
love to go someday but uh but they knew
about it my friend at dinner knew about
it in other words jim and trillions of
dollars of
and the countless lives that were lost
precious individual lives lost in
america because you know and you'd think
with this huge apparatus uh that they'd
be capable of doing something preventing
something and i don't want to get into
politics i i hate politics and that's
why i'm an astronomer because there's no
democratic comet there's no republican
asteroid right so talk about the
government like could they do could they
cover up something like this could they
do it malevolently as you're saying the
cia's basically let's just call it what
it is you're saying they're comprised of
good people good men and women honest
patriots um how come they weren't on top
of something like covid which was you
know known to my dinner party guests
well you know
let me just say this uh the last 10
years
i consulted with the intelligence
community and i was working on uh
counter biological weapons uh and one of
the uh corollaries of that was you know
working on pandemics and talking about
pandemics i can't tell you how many
meetings i sat in with the government
from people that did nothing
but talk about the coming pandemic cia
has written intelligence assessments on
it so has dia i mean almost every
government agency has come out and
warned
people that this is going to be
happening down the road and it's just a
question of
when but the problem with this is um
nobody listens the government does not
listen congress doesn't listen and the
senate doesn't listen until it happens
and when it happens they jump up in the
air start pointing fingers it's it's a
shame it really truly is 911 was the
same way we were screaming you know
bloody murder about uh you know about
osama bin laden this is this is what's
going to happen and we think this is
going to happen soon and people just
look at it and you know say well i don't
really believe it could happen right but
um now in many i mean there are a lot of
times where the intelligence community
fails but but a lot of these no we were
not we were right on top of all this
early on
but nobody wanted to spend money
billions of dollars creating
uh say a a a you know a vaccine that
that could you know help you know
something when when there wasn't one
when there wasn't a when there wasn't a
pathogen out there yet so
and you know the government budgets i
mean like we can have a whole program on
on government budget and how money is
spent and it's usually spent on
quarterly things the things that you
absolutely have to do so anything that's
looking in the future like uaps by the
way you know low probability high impact
events like that they don't get the kind
of
attention they deserve
but you're right i agree with you
you want to ask
some of your viewers questions
yeah well about the government not
participating in disinformation i'm
curious there's
mk ultra project mockingbird or
operation mockingbird and
and
project blue book and quite a few others
so what do you make of that and also
even if it is illegal it's not as if the
government hasn't done what's illegal
before oh no no the government has do
for your government only oh absolutely
i'm not making excuses for the
government i mean the government
has done some terrible things it wasn't
until
1976 for instance when the cia was was
held held accountable is really when all
that stopped when mk ultra came out and
and um i can't remember the name of the
commission but it was uh gerald ford was
running it and uh it
uh
actually gave presentations on it i
don't know why it's slipping my mind
right now but but essentially a ramparts
magazine had a big article on this and
and the and the intelligence community
just changed right there i mean mk ultra
was a program
you know they were experimenting with
you know with with hallucinogenics
because they thought they'd control
people's minds because they knew that
the russians were experimenting with it
so they were doing it
it was a terrible terrible program um
and it was an awful program people died
but you know and then they burned all
the files so we don't know what the hell
happened um uh and and this this has
gone on through you know
throughout the government and very
beginnings but as the government gets
older and as we learn from these
mistakes things really do get better um
uh so yeah i mean when you look at like
the condon report that was a it was a
total whitewash
total whitewash
and
and they basically came out and said you
know we're just gonna we're just gonna
make fun of people who believe in uaps
and ufos and all this kind of stuff and
they shouldn't have done that
uh and it was actually one of the
reasons why
a lot of us in this
these unofficial government workers
decided we're going to go out we're
going to take this private
and i we told the highest levels of
government that's what we're going to be
doing
because they can't seem to get this out
i don't know why i've that talks with
them but they can't get it out and none
of them had any issues with us doing
this they didn't have any issues with
tom i mean it was just go ahead go ahead
and keep us posted
if you want you know and we do
we do and if we ever come across
information we'll share it with them um
you know we're not
anti-government by any stretch of the
imagination but we certainly don't show
for them and we certainly don't work for
them
i have a quick question
are you aware of any government whether
it's our own having possession of
an alien body
are you asking me any
jim or tom i'm not going to comment on
it yeah
i'm not you know i think there's no way
for us to be aware i mean we all hear
the stories we all talk about it online
or read about it online
um you know we're that's one of the
reasons why we're trying to figure out
about the material that we got so
we have material from a purported crash
in the late 40s we don't really have a
chain of title all the way back then we
do for like 20 years or something we
know there's a lot of anomalies about
the way it's engineered we have some
theories of what it can do there's been
a lot of studies on it the government's
very interested in this piece but if
that piece ended up being real then it's
like well what else was it a part of and
who was piloting this thing was it a
drone was it not i think it kind of
it
gets us to ask a lot of questions um
i have you know i'm i'm under the
thinking that you know if there's things
that have been around here for thousands
of years then there's absolutely the
potential for some of these stories to
be real the problem is is like
you're not going to get anybody to come
out
and just say that um
so easily i i think that there's steps
to this you know i look at the task
force report and i look at what's going
on now and
and if i
if there was such a thing like bodies or
craft or whatever
um
and they're so advanced and they're
somehow
influencing
the you know mankind and the way we are
engineered to evolve or something crazy
i mean because i look at us now it's
like first we we got into the biology of
our bodies and then we got deeper and we
got into like you know um dna and what
that's doing and every time we master
parts of the body and parts of you know
the world we see and touch and feel like
what's the next thing well i think the
next thing's going to be discovering
consciousness and then we're going to go
how do we manipulate consciousness and
how do we capture it and how do we are
you know so i'm kind of thinking if this
these beings have been around for so
long they must be in they must be so far
beyond like wondering about our dna or
wondering about like what our spleen
does i think it's going to be
probably
unnerving probably complicated probably
a lot that we don't know and so the idea
of the government just coming out and
saying hey look what we got before they
know what it is doesn't make any sense
to me and i tell my friends this i go if
someone like jim
caught some dude sneaking a nuclear
weapon you know through the border
of canada somewhere into the states you
know are they going to stop and tell us
all about it and really just talk about
it or are they going to go and try and
track down the guy who he was working
with where he got the parts where the
device is got it goes on and it might
take some time now imagine if that
device was like handing an iphone to a
cow and the cow was like i gotta figure
out what this iphone is so i think that
the logical steps that one would take
are exactly kind of what's happening
which was
a number of years trying to figure out
something trying to come up with a plan
that helped understand it or whatever
and then it's like okay now let's create
a proper organization to start getting
more data and letting people know that
the data is real and that we need to
study this and then over time being able
to say this is what we learned you know
it's real and now we're studying it and
this is how they fly and it looks like
they might be doing this and that you
know and so i think we're doing the
logical steps now that might one day
lead to
we've collected some stuff you know but
i don't think that if they even if they
did
i wouldn't knowing what i know about
this subject which isn't like a lot i
feel like it's a lot but but who knows
um because they say like studying space
is like if we were to study the oceans
it's like we know a half a cup of water
of the oceans yeah that's how much we
know about space yeah so i just i think
this is i think you're seeing
a rational logical progression of
something extremely complicated starting
to be formed to come out after a long
period of time of digging in and trying
to wrap their heads around it that's
what it looks like to me
and you in particular tom you know doing
yeoman's work to make this less taboo to
make it into the public consciousness um
and yet i'm curious how you react to my
colleagues professors astronomers who
spend our days you know i heard um i
heard commander fraver saying on lex
friedman's podcast you know we are
trained pilots we are trying to use our
senses our eyes and our tools and our
technology well so are astronomers we're
pretty good at looking up and things in
space we survey the sky with high
cadence with quite great frequency some
right here in southern california as you
know look out your window and see mount
palomar uh but i want to ask you how do
you react to those that say well
astronomers would like nothing better
than for these craft to be real again so
that we could bypass the the line and
skip from the equivalent of euclid 2000
years ago to uh to einstein you know
that would be a tremendous boost towards
humanity and no one would have a
negative state in that in the
astronomical community you might say the
government does
and that they want to keep us you know
comfortable and happy and not in
revolution but big astronomy doesn't
exist so how do you react to that that
astronomers would like nothing more for
these to be real we don't have credible
reports in any sensor and any wavelength
any frequency any polarization time of
day a year that where it's really
credibly come out and been verified
peer-reviewed however you like to say it
how do you react to those kinds of of
assertions
um well two two things for me and i
think jim will have some really great
insight on this um as usual but i the
two things for me are number one there
has been that stuff it has been picked
up that was one of chris mellon's big
pushes is that all of these satellites
that are doing thermal imaging watching
animal migrations weather satellites spy
satellites that collects data all day
long and he's like we need to scan that
data and we need to find out you know if
this weather satellite picked up um
you know uh
there's a little roman right there you
need sound you need to send this weather
satellite picked up something flying
through but these satellites aren't
really geared to pick up things moving
20 000 miles an hour and doing a 90
degree turn but it still might be in
there but we have to do some software to
kind of pull it out but then we have the
videos that come out there's so many
more videos that we know that are
probably classified not so much because
of what's on it but maybe where they
filmed it or how good the resolution is
or whatever those things are but those
things do exist we've filmed these
things the military has them the
government has them on the best systems
that have ever been created in the
history of man on the spy one radar the
uss princeton and these top gun pilots
and top gun radar controllers capturing
this stuff with with their eyeballs with
the sensors with the people in the
planes all that stuff is there the
second thing is is i don't personally
and i don't know this but i don't think
these are coming from space i don't
think they're coming from deep space so
if we're looking
at the oceans but we're wondering where
we're going to find a planet
you know you're not going to find one
there you know so i think
it's better that we're
monitoring
you know the area around our planet and
and what things are materializing in
this realm in that so i think
astronomers are looking far out and i'm
not exclu i'm not saying that there
aren't there isn't other life out there
and they're not sending drones out or
maybe they're got advanced enough to
travel i'm not saying that i just have
this feeling that the universe
is more of a duality structure where
time can extend in two directions in the
exact same moment in the exact same
place which means people that are very
advanced or things that are very
advanced can just pop over
like a radio station and
that's why we're not seeing them because
we're looking out at mars or we're
looking out at like alpha centauri and
we're like where's it coming from you
know it's like no it's it's in utah it's
just in the future or something and um
so i think i think we're gonna learn and
think around
those lines um and and i think
astronomers are totally capable i mean
these are some of the smartest people in
the world i think maybe it's like adding
to
like their perv it's like adding to what
they look for and look at and where they
look would be kind of cool you know
getting you guys to look at
you know frequency and duality theory
and time existing at one moment in the
same location and you know so it's not
just looking at stars it's kind of react
to the new project galileo professor
gavi loeb who is the chairman of the
harvard astronomy
department for longer than any other
person you feel like that's a sign of
progress that that's being made and
mainstreaming it
um any anybody that's interested in
looking for these things and treating
them as real is is really good for the
scientific community um that's why our
company exists is to like create that
opportunity where the stigma is gone
um
i'll tell you like
i
it's so all the conversations i've had
with people that really do know a lot
about this stuff um
it you know they can only talk about so
much so even i was on the wrong path 50
different times for like years i really
thought i understood something and then
all of a sudden someone else says one
more thing and it changes everything i
thought i knew and i was like oh my god
i got it so wrong and then you know it's
it it's difficult to comprehend
especially for a guy like me i'm not
like you i don't i didn't go to college
i didn't study science i don't have
but i that ability but i'm a pretty
clever guy and i could find patterns
pretty easily um and uh and i'm
constantly learning i'm constantly open
to learning um but i just think that
that these scientists and
i'll give you an example i mean i won't
go into too much detail because i don't
feel comfortable doing it but i i there
was a very important person
that i met early on long before i knew
jim
and i and i remember that somebody that
was a very high-ranking person at a very
important government place said you
should meet this person he's a very
interesting
person very high-ranking person and uh
and i said cause i pitched this idea of
what to the stars could be and so this
person comes to san diego they put me on
the phone with this other person and
said hey this is tom and he's got some
great ideas about how to talk to the
youth about you know life in the
universe and so on this person on the
phone was like well there's no evidence
for that i don't believe in any of that
um it's just not my thing but why don't
you fly up tomorrow
come meet me you know and i was like to
talk about what something that doesn't
exist so i remember this person that's
the airport a visit that you talked
about on rogan no no this is some no
this is something different
but it led to that and so this person
was just like it was a two-hour
conversation none of it's real none of
it exists but i want to hear what your
plan is or what you're trying to achieve
you know and i remember this person was
setting up a venture to look for life in
the universe somewhere with some really
cool technology and a lot of money um i
don't want to say too much um
and i was like you know sir you're
you're looking for life out there you
are raising all this money and you're
doing this great thing for humanity and
i believe it's out there i'm all but i
i want to talk about the ones that are
here i think young people need to know
about the ones that are here and i
remember banging on the table you know
because i knew that the meeting was kind
of varying after two hours like you know
it was gonna get shut down i was gonna
get anywhere so i got really full of
passion and i was like you want to look
out there great i need your help because
i want to discuss what's here the ones
here you know and then he took a deep
breath
and then he just looked at me and then
he and then he said he goes let's
introduce him to so and so and then the
other guy next to him turns his head and
he goes are you sure he goes yeah i'm
sure
and that's how it led to that other
meeting and the next thing you know you
got these people gathering around that
want to talk about what's here but
they're very limited on what they can
say so i have to like
kind of put things together and then
fortunately i meet jim and jim teaches
me a lot about how to absorb information
and how to digest it and how to hold on
to it even if it doesn't because it
doesn't have enough about it that means
anything yet but it might be important
later um i'm not him but i i'm trying to
learn as much as i can from him and so
it it the whole thing is just wild like
it it's very real and there's a
difference between what's out there and
what's here and it might be there might
be a lot more than that too the universe
is big you know there could be infinite
possibility out there yeah
yeah i i i just add a quick thing about
science and scientists in general
regarding this uap phenomenon
i feel so sorry for them in many
respects i am a huge fan of of the
galileo project i i just think it's
wonderful and i think
what he's going to be doing and what you
guys are all going to be doing with that
is is is really necessary i just applaud
how courageous you guys are going out
and doing that and dr loeb is doing that
um i i will say
i haven't met very many scientists uh
that are in that are doing something
like this or whether they're skeptics or
what have you that have a really
sound understanding of the literature
and the research that has been done over
the last 70 years on this topic i think
if they did they'd have a better
appreciation
for what they're going against or what
they're trying to figure out um
personally
based on my knowledge and based on what
i know i don't think we're ever going to
come to at least not in my lifetime i'm
an older guy now but
in my lifetime we're ever going to come
to any kind of conclusion about what
this phenomenon actually is i think it
encompasses a lot more than uaps
i think there's a huge trickster element
to it
um
i could go on uh you know but but i'll
just i'll just say that i i appreciate
the fact that science is doing this i
think eventually
science is going to have to
figure out another way to approach this
um
because as tom keeps mentioning
consciousness and what have you i i
spoke to a scientist once and and uh who
was very involved in this and i asked
him i said what do you think's behind
all this this this phenomenon and he
said it's somewhere in between
consciousness and you know a nexus of
consciousness and and you know quantum
quantum theory quantum mechanics but
when you're talking about quantum
mechanics and you know when i ask you
about superpositioning or asking about
quantum entanglement or the particle
wave theory and what have you you can't
explain it scientists can't really
explain it but it's in a box it's in the
quantum theory box and it's a it's a
place they can put it and there's
something there but when you talk about
uaps there is no ontology there there's
there's no
way there's a lexicon that you can
actually use to even begin the
discussion we can't even figure out what
questions to ask about this because we
don't know what it is there's no there
there as i said before and that's what
makes this extremely difficult and i
think that's why scientists many
scientists are extremely frustrated over
this the evidence there is some heart
evidence that i feel that's hard
evidence science some scientists don't
believe that's true but a lot of the a
lot of what we have is anecdotal and
they might call soft evidence but
nevertheless it's there as i said before
these tic tacs that were flying over the
nimitz
they're real they were absolutely 100
real and please don't tell me there are
sensor anomalies i know they weren't
sensor anomalies they were absolutely
real so what do you do with that
and so if you're a scientist you say
well show me you know
i got to see them again i got to take
this is what i love about the galileo
project i want to take a good picture
that is the perfect thing to say because
that's exactly what we need we need a
good picture first
and um there are some out there by the
way but um i don't know if they're
classified are they classified yeah
great pictures and i think lou's even
mentioned this a couple of times that
some of the evidence that we do have is
rather compelling and and uh but there
is um there's a problem with releasing
them uh regarding some of the uh
uh sensor systems that we have and you
can't give away
you know what we're right now i see yeah
so i have a question a quick question
about consciousness and then i have to
leave pretty soon or my wife will kill
me okay so consciousness this trickster
element you mentioned now at the same
time there's also steve greer i believe
it's grier who said that there's a
project called ce5 or at least
a technique of ce5 of connecting
yourself with an alien via some
meditative technique or perhaps even
psychedelic some trans state some
abnormal consciousness state altered
state
what do you make of this
well i think about well let me say one
thing about steven greer i i've never
met the man um um i do take my hat off
to him he's done some incredible work
early on
uh he's not a big fan of our
organization at all and i'm not quite
sure why uh but he isn't but as far as
what he's doing with ce5 and what have
you i
i don't have any comment on that i i i
don't go that far i mean it's
tom you wanna yeah my feeling um
is that you know again
if you look at just what we've done as
human beings over the past hundred years
where it's like we first you know we
invent the telephone and then radio
waves and communicating over different
frequencies and then we're able to tap
phones and we're able to tap you know
hack into radio whatever like you just
look at the progression that we're doing
i would bet money
that down the line when we're
technologically advanced we're gonna not
be hacking radio waves we're gonna be
hacking minds we're gonna be listening
in to what people are thinking and
what is the loudest that someone can be
when they're thinking i would imagine
it's a group of people that are that are
meditating together they're all thinking
the same thing at the same moment you
know so it's almost like if you're
searching around for a light in the dark
that's a brighter light so part of me
really does subscribe to
um you know consciousness and meditation
and the focusing of one's mind on is
being something that
that something advanced could easily get
into i mean you when you look at the
evidence or you look at the data of the
people involved it's you know you can be
paralyzed or you hear voices in your
head or you know there's it's always
something to do
with you know kind of hacking the system
to a degree um so i i think that that's
all plays a big part of it and uh and i
definitely believe it you know i just
think that it needs to be studied
scientifically yeah i agree i i don't
discount what stephen grier is saying i
i i you know it could possibly be true i
just don't know enough about it uh um uh
but
but i applaud that he's actually working
on it but you know
now when you uh we do have some
questions in the audience you want to
know how they can be involved what can
they do obviously project galileo is
privately funded that's at harvard uh
what what about your endeavors guys what
would you like to turn to people to
attention to to get involved if they're
interested in joining this mission well
we created a public company a public
benefit company because a company so our
goal was like if we're gonna do this we
can't do this where just a few people
own it you know so we have up for
somewhere between 3 500 4 000 investors
where we let people come and be a part
of this and help grow the company so we
can do exactly this we can tell the
stories we can do the research we can
help push the government we can kind of
become a credible place to discuss this
stuff so that's one avenue support ttsa
you know be an owner of it with us um
and help us get the job done look what
we've done so far on very little the
second thing is i say this this is just
me talking this isn't a to the stars
position or anything don't let the
government um
sit quietly and and just go off and they
say one thing and then we just trust it
it's fine these are human beings that
work there that get distracted that get
overburdened with other jobs they got to
do that really there's not much in it
for these guys
you know that are working some of these
difficult issues to come out to start
talking about it and have everyone start
calling their office and like bugging
them and now they can't get their job
done and now they got to go brief a
bunch of senators that just want to be
on tv and get more votes but so you know
but i think that people need to not
let them live this down you know you got
to bring this up when they're
interviewing the president you got to
bring this up when they're when the
congressmen are having debates the
senators are having debates to get
re-elected you got to bring this up in
the press environment you know when the
when the the pr person is talking for
the dod or talking for the cia or
talking for
any place that might have stakes in this
but when we're quiet and complacent and
just read a report that it's all real
but we don't really like follow up blows
my mind i mean it blows my mind that
people are not beating down the door
right now going wait what this is real
how much do you really know that you're
not telling us well in my own personal
opinion i think they know a hell of a
lot more than we know and i think they
have a hell of a good reason probably
for not talking about all of it i i i
because in my experience
with all these government guys they're
all really good people and they're smart
and they're ethical they're humans and
make mistakes uh and new laws get
created for more oversight and so on so
we don't have a repeat of the mk ultra
stuff or whatever but i've met a lot of
these people and a lot of them are just
bound by the
by the ethics or the rules of how it
works it's like they create a black
program but there's no part of a
classified program that i know of that's
ever been spoken of me where it's kind
of like okay now comes the part where we
tell everybody about it it just doesn't
exist so then how do you tell everybody
about it i mean jim can talk about it
better than i can but the only way is
pressure pressure pressure pressure
pressure and then finally they they have
to act for the will of the people and so
yeah that's what you need to do don't
let them down don't let it go quietly no
no and
i couldn't agree with tom anymore i mean
it's he's absolutely right in what he
just said and uh you know this is one of
the reasons we we formed ttsa i remember
i remember talking with lou
uh when he was on the task force and
being in the pentagon and talking to
some of the officers there uh they were
very concerned about this phenomenon
they you know they knew it was real they
just didn't know what to do about it and
i kept telling them you know look you
know you got to go you got to go public
with this and if you can't go public
you know you know we i just formed a
company with tom delong and i said we're
going to take this private we're going
to go to the private sector because the
government does not own this data the
government doesn't own uaps or the study
of uaps or the research it belongs to
everybody it doesn't just appear to
carry your strike groups it appears
everywhere to all people around the
world it's appearing in argentina in
china you know in bangladesh so
we really as as human beings have to get
together and that's when we said we're
taking this private and and we will we
won't discuss classified information but
we are going private the public has to
be more informed about this and let them
know that their consensus reality the
reality we all agree on
isn't
quite right
there's something else going on and we
really truly have to figure that out
because that's what we do as human
beings
well guys thank you so much i'll let it
go with that and i really do have to
leave and i i really enjoying this very
very much
i'm enjoying it as well yeah let's do a
part two jim let's do it again i'll be
more than happy to do it again with you
guys yeah it's just it'll be fun in
doing doing and doing another one um but
digging into
not so much you know is it real and what
the government's doing or not but really
just let's dig into
you know what it's
you know something more about what it's
about what it's doing or like something
that's not just government because jim
has a lot of knowledge that's right yeah
that would be a really
yeah the physics implication get young
people interested in thinking big look
sometimes it borders on sci-fi sometimes
it has a stigma but nevertheless if we
can inspire just one mind as they say to
take physics seriously to learn and with
the artist eye of tom with the patriotic
eye of jim with the inquisitive nature
of kurt and maybe with the scientists
perspective that i'm trying to bring i
think we're doing a good service so i'd
love to do that again guys uh tom thank
you so much for your generation yeah i
love your work uh big fan maybe kurt
next time you'll take out your guitar
and you'll teach thomas j wards or
something man that'll be fun dude i only
know three chords i'm in a punk band i
mean we don't know any more than three
so that's what we do oh we love you man
and uh kurt thank you so much brother
and jim it's honor and a pleasure thank
you for your service to the country my
honor tom thank you so much